the artisan boutique hotel you know the
ones right off the 15 and sahara well
they have a new owner and a new design
and it could be the first
marijuana-friendly hotel in the city a
pro hospitality group purchasing the
property located right there in the
heart of the valley for a little over 11
million dollars mary jane belliesa
shares the property owner's big new
plans
it's the first hotel boutique of its
kind here in the las vegas valley pro
hospitality group ceo alex risk says the
artisan hotel boutique will include
cannabis all-inclusive activities
the artisan is a real
unique and historical you know asset the
inspiration comes from the clarendon
hotel which the group owns and operates
in phoenix wrist says he partnered with
marquis commercial to acquire the
artisan the primary thing we really want
to focus on is the love for the locals
you know the
everyone from the dealers to the
bartenders to the the late night crews
that when they finish work they have a
they have their own little sanctuary
that they can come to artisan hotel
boutique could be the first marijuana
friendly hotel in las vegas depending on
the state's final decision on cannabis
ordinances and licensing laws
basically uh create or design our
cannabis program around what will be
allowed to be done
we are a hotel first and then we'll
design our program around
what will be
the new legal
format moving forward he says guests can
expect five course gourmet meals infused
with cannabis served by celebrity chefs
high potent cbd spa treatments and they
are working to partner with dispensaries
in the valley if for some reason the
laws wouldn't work with with for this we
would still have you know this
great
boutique
fun
revived hotel the cannabis consumption
when we are able to do those with the
state it's just a bonus
it's part of the experience mary jane
valleja live local now